las personas que ves en esta fotografía
son dos astronautas de la nasa que
además resultan ser gemelos idénticos
del lado derecho tengo a markel y aquí
puedes ver el nombre en su uniforme y su
hermano es scott kelly la razón del por
qué quiero que veamos a estos dos
astronautas en particular es para pensar
en el genotipo y el fenotipo que hemos
estudiado en otros vídeos como un
pequeño repaso
cuando hablamos de genotipo estamos
hablando de la información genética
actual codificada en los genes del
organismo es decir si nos vamos al
interior de una célula sabemos que
tenemos cromosomas y cada uno de esos
cromosomas es una larga cadena de adn
algunas secciones de esas cadenas de adn
codificarán para algunas cosas a menudo
para varias proteínas pero hay una gran
diferencia entre la información
existente en los genes y la que en
verdad se expresa por otra parte las
características observables son el
fenotipo dos personas con el mismo que
no tipo deberán tener un fenotipo
similar pero no necesariamente el mismo
fenotipo porque más allá de que los
genes afectan el fenotipo el medio
ambiente también afecta aquí puedes ver
que mark y scott kelly son gemelos
idénticos ellos tienen el mismo genotipo
pero si analiza sus características
faciales puedes ver que hay varias
diferencias entre ambos no es sólo que
market tiene bigote mientras que scott
no porque podremos dibujar un bigote y
seguiríamos viendo diferencias y eso es
porque sus cuerpos se desarrollaron de
forma distinta
de acuerdo al ambiente en el que se han
desenvuelto ahora bien a esta idea de
que el mismo que no tipo puede resultar
en variaciones del fenotipo se le conoce
como plasticidad fenotípica
uno de los experimentos más extremos que
se han llevado a cabo sobre plasticidad
fenotípica fue uno en donde la nasa
quiso investigar qué es lo que pasaría
con la expresión genética de scott si
pasaba un largo periodo de tiempo en el
espacio mientras que su hermano gemelo
no
ellos observaron como sus cuerpos
muestran ciertas características antes
de que scott pasar a ese largo periodo
de tiempo en el espacio y después de que
pasó ese largo periodo de tiempo en el
espacio estudiaron su cuerpo y
observaron grandes diferencias en las
mitocondrias y en cómo se expresaron sus
genes de hecho un 17 por ciento de
diferencia en la expresión de sus genes
después de que scott estuviera un largo
periodo de tiempo en el espacio este es
un ejemplo de cómo el ambiente del
espacio cambió el fenotipo de scott los
científicos de la nasa teorizaron que un
ambiente con poco oxígeno y abundante
dióxido de carbono y las tensiones de un
viaje espacial afectaron la expresión
del genotipo de scott porque recuerda
que es idéntico al genotipo de su
hermano marc dando como resultado la
plasticidad fenotípica mucho más allá de
otros cambios del fenotipo que han
acumulado a lo largo de sus vidas y a
pesar de tener la misma información
genética
bueno eso es todo por este vídeo nos
vemos en el siguiente